you have a fun anniversary coming up so
i want to take you back if i can 20
years ago okay you guest start on
friends oh my god i was like what's my
interview i saw i saw your episode
recently did you yeah you were joey's
sister i'm pregnant
what
now give him the sandwich give him the
sandwich
so what do you remember about shooting
with the cast oh man i just if i talk
about surreal like that was extremely
surreal for me like i was such a huge
fan of the show so once i you know got
that part
everything was just so cool the sets
being around them and a lot of people
are like post a picture of you with you
know the i don't have no pictures i did
not take a picture
like camera phone i didn't have my
disposable camera with me right still
you were like with the rolling stones of
tv
i have zero pictures and um yeah i just
have like the memories and it was such a
great memory and that episode seems to
air like every week yeah
because they play they replay everything
and i
every day i'm watching two or three
episodes of friends yeah it's hilarious
that's like home alone it stands up that
you know that you're never like oh this
didn't age well or there's certain
things that don't play anymore like
totally still just dead on we're still
doing the retrospective because you've
been in the business for such a long
time and actually we've been with you
guys here at et for a very oh gosh are
you going to show stuff oh thank you
come on you know we are we want to take
you back
to my
both of your very first et interviews oh
my gosh stop it yeah
so we were with you uh we went ceramic
painting with you back in 1999. do you
remember doing there no no clue like a
coloring line or something like yes like
a ceramic painting place and then hayley
we went with you and hillary to the vmas
in 2003. we kind of rode along oh gosh
i'm so scared of what this outfit is
take a look at both of these like what
oh man i made a tissue box a few weeks
ago and when i made it i thought it was
amazing and i picked it up and i was
like oh my gosh like i'm just
embarrassed to show it to anybody hi
this is haley we take each other as
dates for everything that's right no
boys
no boys boys are
done
go out for a while no boys
[Music]
why were you at a ceramic place with me
though how did that all go down i need
to know the back story i know i wish i
knew but the fact that we were with you
just ceramic painting is the best thing
like and it'd just be so
self-deprecating like it's very you know
it's very you though it's to be like i
thought it was great but then you know
what do you think that when you when you
guys both see those girls and like you
know what would you say to them today
gosh
yeah i probably would say like something
so hard on yourself about everything
because i was then and i still am um but
that specific time in my life i feel
like was such an exciting time i had so
many you know like i was on the practice
and i i'm like i hope i enjoyed it you
know i hope i wasn't obsessing about
silly teenage stuff
we definitely were yeah we definitely
were yeah i probably would ask myself um
why my eyebrows were so dark and my hair
was so light
and i probably would ask a couple
questions about those bangs yeah you're
so silly and you would say uh stop lying
there will be boys yeah there will
always be lots of boys there you go by
the way speaking of boys and what
happens when you get with a boy you're
pregnant
yes watch out for those boys for real
you're gonna have your third baby girl
i'm gonna have my third baby
yeah third baby look at those girls our
little surprise is joining our family oh
my gosh so what do you your girls think
about being a big sister again they're
so excited my little one was like
you know when we told her she was really
she was excited she was like oh this is
so great and then she was like balling
his favorite turn her into a little
child honey correct oh boy she was the
baby she's jam brady now marsha marsha
marsha but now she's really excited this
was just like the initial like reveal
for them um they're gonna be the best
big sisters actually that's how hayley
and i became like super close is our
daughters are the same age and we did it
was a ballet they were in ballet
together ballet um something else too
and then we were at similar preschools
but different locations but we have tons
of like mutual mom friends cause you
have and i met your older one
i mean i remember when olive was like
little little i mean elliot was little
little yeah yep crazy you have two girls
at home and you have a new niece yeah so
like christmas time in your household is
it like just the chaos well this will be
our first christmas in texas because
we've moved to austin so this will be
our first christmas in our house there
which is gonna be like so different and
crazy um but i'm really excited for it
i'm excited for the holidays this year i
think everyone's really like
ready for some down time and some fun
and yeah
i want to throw a lot of love marla's
way for cast at large and for those big
scenes with extras and everything
she did great frankly felt like our old
set and haley it was a pleasure and a
privilege are you a little touchy that
actually almost made me cry i'm not
kidding i'm like really i'm so i did not
expect that she got those pregnancy
hormones just going they're going well
if you're wondering why the brady bunch
cast was sending them all that love
that's because haley starred alongside
of them in the new lifetime movie
blending christmas premiering sunday and
marlon directed well i took the liberty
of printing out some of the lyrics
not that i think you guys need them but
all blank zone
yeah what about it it's not a christmas
song
of course it is it's an old scottish
folk song it has nothing to do with
christmas except for that it's sung at
christmas time
it's sung at new year's okay we can
worry about that later
shall we begin what was the best part
about working with the we can still call
them the brady kids they're they're
always going to be yeah i think so right
yeah yeah
what was best for you i mean i don't
know i feel like if you would have told
my like 10 year old self watching reruns
homesick that i was going to direct the
bradys one day i probably would never
believe you so for me there was this
level of um surrealness and then just
being able to collaborate with them was
so great
for me i think it was seeing their
genuine connection with each other how
much they genuinely love each other they
loved being around each other you could
see like a true camaraderie and i think
you know being in this business like you
wonder well they worked together so long
ago like are they going to get along
what's going to be like and they were
just so wonderful yeah we've done
projects with them and and it is very
true they
are a family honestly yes they love each
other they really really do and i wonder
did you guys bond with them too because
all of you all were child actors
how funny
yeah every single one of you i'm like is
that that's kind of a common thread you
come in and you all kind of get each
other's experience right away well you
know i think it is also coming out of
like being at home for so long everyone
was so grateful to be on a set be with
other people be doing what we love that
there was such a great energy to the set
it was like everyone was happy to be
there you asked him to stay a little
longer sure like you know because there
was like a way this was like deep in the
pandemic like we shot this like in
february really yeah so i mean you know
we were still people were still kind of
inside yeah yeah everyone was just like
happy to be there it was definitely my
first like foray out into the world i
was like okay we're doing this we're
doing it i'm outside yes you're real
yeah
and i got to do it with her which was
amazing because marlon i've been friends
for a very long time so
being able to go be on set and have her
as like boss lady was the best yeah it
was comforting to see you every day like
oh haley when it was over i was like no
i know yeah you actually we can call you
the christmas movie queen because you've
done your fair share yeah of christmas
movies you definitely had why do you
just love them so much you know i think
there's something about just being able
to have a departure from the world and
watch something that just makes you feel
good doesn't make you like think about
your own life or anything deep you're
just like able to turn it on zone out
have a glass of wine or whatever it is
cozy up and just have like a feel-good
moment
[Music]
you